american science journalist joshua 4
always thought his brain was pretty
average
but one day in 2005 while covering
the usa national memory championship a
competition
designed to test the limits of the human
brain
he's presented with an unusual
opportunity
a former champion offers to train him to
become
a mental athlete over the course of a
year
joshua learns ancient methods like
memory palaces this is where you
associate pieces of information
with a location in your mind to make
them
unforgettable he also uses cutting-edge
mnemonic techniques which allow him to
remember hundreds of playing cards
in a specific order soon
joshua's competitive instinct takes over
he trains in his parents basement
for hours a day by 2006
he's ready to attend the championship
again but this time
not as a journalist but as a competitor
round after round joshua the newcomer
gives former champions
a run for their money he makes it to the
final
despite being up against a formidable
opponent he uses the brain training
methods he was taught
and wins
how could a novice like joshua become a
champion
so quickly does this mean that anybody
could become a mental athlete
to really understand joshua's success we
need to consider the role
of opportunity it was long thought that
richer children did better than poorer
children in school
because they were more naturally gifted
but now we know that it's times when
children aren't in school
including the long school holidays when
poorer children
lack access to extracurricular
activities that often create
an attainment gap nutrition and access
to technology
also make a contribution which is partly
why
iq scores across the globe rose an
average of 30 points
in the 20th century factors that have
literally nothing to do
with genetics when it comes to
differences in outcome
it's not nature but nurture which has
the greater impact
and it's the same with joshua iv his
expert training
access to special techniques his
opponents hadn't yet discovered
and a quiet place to study his parents
basement
that all contributed to his success
though it's also worth knowing that
despite being a memory champion
even joshua can sometimes forget where
he put his car keys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos
next and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video